inutile hier il est désormais quasi
obligatoire sur le port du masque l
exécutif a pris un virage à 180 degrés
l'histoire vous la connaissez le coc vie
de 19 à paray cet hiver à aux ânes en
chine et provoque des milliers de morts
mais une certitude le risque
d'importation du virus en france est
très faible pratiquement nul
le 24 janvier ce n'est pas la première
venue qu'il affirme assez agnès buzyn
alors ministre de la santé en termes de
risque pour la france des analyses de
risques d'importation sont modélisés
régulièrement par les équipes de
recherche
le risque d'importation de cas depuis ou
anne est modérée il est maintenant
pratiquement nulle puisque la ville vous
le savez est isolé les risques de cas
secondaires autour d'un cas importé sont
très faibles et les risques de
propagation du virus dans la population
sont très faibles
deux jours plus tard la france compte 73
cas de contamination et agnès buzyn
conseil
aujourd'hui il n'y a aucune indication
acheter des masques pour la population
française la ministre de la santé est
loin d'être la seule responsable à tenir
ce discours
les matchs n'ont aucun intérêt pour le
grand public le port du masque en
population générale dans la rue ça ne
sert à rien je suis surpris de voir par
la fenêtre de mon ministère le nombre de
personnes qui sont dans la rue avec des
masques alors que cela ne correspond pas
des recommandations
ils ne sont pas utiles et ils sont trop
compliqué d'utilisation pour le français
moyen voire contre-productif à en croire
le gouvernement
vous savez quoi moi je sais pas utiliser
un masque je pourrais dire je suis mini
je me mets un masque mais en fait je
sais pas l'utiliser parce que
l'utilisation d'un masque ce sont des
gestes techniques précis il n'y a pas de
preuve que le port du masque dans la
population apportera un bénéfice ce
serait plutôt le contraire
à cause d'une mauvaise utilisation le 16
avril c'est le chef de l'état en
personne qui s'exprime sur le sujet je
refuse de recommander le port du masque
pour tous et jamais le gouvernement ne
l'a fait et pourtant c'est ce que fait
son premier mini
str trois jours plus tard les transports
sont un des cas où le port du masque
pourra être obligatoire à compter du 11
mai le port du masque obligatoire dans
les transports en commun obligatoire
pour les collégiens et peut-être même
bientôt partout en france dans l'espace
public
pourquoi donc cette volte-face du
gouvernement sur le port du masque
s'agissait-il sans mauvais jeu de mots
de masquer une certaine pénurie le
gouvernement aurait-il adapter ses
consignes sanitaires en fonction des
stocks disponibles
ce que l'on sait c'est qu'il y a dix ans
la france disposait aide d'un milliard
de masques chirurgicaux contre 140
millions seulement au début de la crise
mi février la france envoyait est de 17
tonnes de matériel médical à la chine
alors que le virus avait déjà atteint
l'hexagone
une fois la crise passée l exécutif
devra certainement rendre des comptes à
ce jour au moins cinquante cinq plaintes
ont déjà été déposées devant la cour de
justice de la république contre
notamment edouard philippe
agnès buzyn l'ancien ministre de la
santé et son successeur olivier ferrand
plainte pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui non assistance à personne en
danger ou homicide involontaire dans le
cadre de l'épidémie de kobe de 19